there's been a lot of talk over the past
few years and in some popular books
about the power of intuition and how if
we trust that our intuitions or went
with our guts more often we would
actually wind up making better decisions
in the world would even be a better
place some researchers have talked about
how our intuitions and the intuitive
judgments we can make the snap judgments
are actually accurate a lot of the time
and a lot of that is true but what we
noticed when thinking about our gorilla
experiment and doing research for this
book is that there's a whole category of
intuitions that are actually
systematically wrong and in very
dangerous ways and those are the
intuitions we have about how our own
minds work
so the gorilla experiment shows that we
intuitively think that we pay attention
to a notice much more than we actually
do and that can have tragic consequences
if you get into a car accident or one of
the examples in our book is a nuclear
submarine that surfaced right into a
Japanese fishing boat because in part
the captain of the submarine looked up
in the periscope didn't see any boats
around and surfaced right into one that
he didn't see that was actually probably
right in front of him so there's an in
case where intuitively we think
something and it can really get us into
big trouble we realized as we were
thinking about the book and putting
together the ideas that this category of
intuitions is very broad it's not just
about visual attention it's also about
memory we think we remember things much
more accurately than we really do it's
about confidence we think that people
who are confident are also more skilled
and accurate and knowledgeable and it's
about our own knowledge we think that we
know and understand more about the world
and we really do and so on they're sort
of like a whole sort of set of these
intuitions which can really lead us
astray if we're not aware of them and
that's what we decided to write the book
about
we are in a way taking on the impression
that a lot of people have from books
like blanked by Malcolm Gladwell and
others in that category which is sort of
an uncritical belief in the power of
intuition and snap judgments and so on
and the idea that you should rely on
them whenever possible we sort of are in
a sense taking on the cult of intuition
or the myth of intuition as we call it
in the book I should also say that we're
very pleased that Malcolm Gladwell
actually read our original scientific
journal article about the invisible
gorilla study and talked about it in one
of his New Yorker articles which helped
it get more publicity and ultimately led
to it becoming more widely known and as
famous as it is